frustrations and worry continue as a lot
of people who've already received their
first dose
are now just scrambling to try and get
that second appointment for their second
vaccine dose
today the health district said emails
are being sent out
joe mohler is live at the las vegas
convention center with more on what's
being said and what's being done
joe
imagine getting that first dose and then
trying to set up a second for a second
dose here at the convention
center but it is all booked up now that
is what many people say is happening to
them
is the one dose going to be even
valuable if i can't get the second nose
when they tell me i should
uh dr and i apologize
patricia clark is worried she won't get
her appointment on february 17th
in a virtual news conference the health
district said they are sending out more
emails about second appointments today
or tomorrow now this is
happening due to technical difficulties
they said that is where
you will set up your next appointment
they also explain the grace period for
the second dose is up to six weeks or 42
days
so if you don't get an appointment right
away when you're supposed to that should
be okay
so if you've had your vaccine from
a january 4 to like the 19th i will we
will be emailing you
for that
they also explained the website is still
being updated and they are working out
the issues now you are encouraged to
keep checking back
in claire county nearly 175 thousand
doses were administered as of yesterday
each week clark county has been
receiving about 23 000 to 25
000 doses on today's vaccine call they
announced next week they will be getting
27
000 doses so that is an increase now we
know many people simply want to talk to
someone on the phone about their
questions now take a look at the number
on your screen
five nine 702-759-1 nine zero zero this
is the number people can call who have
to get the second dose
and have questions about that now we
know that people have been calling and
those phone lines have been busy so
today the health district did say that
they added staff
to help on those phone lines to answer
your questions so that is the number
you're going to want to call reporting
live here at the convention center
darmola 8 news